foreign
[Music]
things are getting bad with the Chinese
man I went to a restaurant just today we
went to a Chinese restaurant in my
fortune cookie it just said we're
watching you I was like oh my God
this is scary
you guys excited for the for the Chinese
surveillance balloon
[Applause]
yeah
good Tick Tock and a balloon they're
getting a little greedy I think but
whoever picked uh Montana
they probably don't know a ton about the
United States
we should spy on the Americans what are
you thinking uh Billings
you don't want to do like California or
Texas or New York like nah dude [__]
I watched this show on Paramount plus
and uh
I got a feeling dude I
that's where the action happens what a
cartoonish this is like a 90s movie like
an early 2000s movie that it we're being
spied on with a balloon is this what try
I thought China was very sophisticated I
thought China was doing like a lot of
corporate Espionage and they had spies
in this country that are born here like
my godson that will grow up and live
here like I thought China was doing this
really high level [__] this is what
they're doing they're setting a hot air
balloon maybe we don't really have to
worry about them this is what they're
doing they're sending a blimp I want to
talk about them Chopstick balloons they
were flying over the United States of
America yeah come on bro yes the Chinese
Lantern Festival can we talk about the
chance
let's talk about it
he's Korean now
oh [__] [__] come on son my back come on
all right so they shot it down it was
flying over America for a few days yeah
right move or wrong move to shoot it
down yeah
or do you think they left it up there to
let everyone know hey China's a bad guy
and then shot it down while everyone was
watching
I mean that's an acceptable reason maybe
we were trying to extract as much
information because we knew that [__]
would get damaged on the way down but
what information you got to extract our
own
the truth is probably a lot less sexy
than people think right people wanted to
be a UFO yeah they want also it's
definitely not also I wanted to be that
that'd be great alien ware what if
they're dumb aliens they like fight face
first they think they overestimate us
they think the binders yeah they knew
about it like NSA knew about it and then
when the guy caught it on his long-range
lens for one second do I think that's a
Chinese spy balloon not hey if MSM is
saying that right if CNN is like oh it's
something else Fair Point do you think
they put it up there to make mine look
good I don't know what maybe I don't
know what they're so they would they
could say oh China's [__] with us and
then we could do things to China you
think China's gonna launch a [__]
balloon across the Pacific Ocean
oh the Spy balloon yeah well it's
[__] spy blue and man inflation is
out of control
Jesus Christ
I'll tell you I flew here on Air Canada
I wish it was a [__] Sky balloon
of Thunder gets around in that seems
like her motive
yeah you know she's uh she's 20. I
always thought she was like nine
I had no idea I thought she's so
youthful man autism don't crack
good for her I mean hey I'm an Asperger
too I can say that and then what does
try I guess we go to China and go you
have a [__] spot on the go oh I don't
know they go we don't really know we
don't just uh it's just a hot air
balloon but this does I'm not I'm am I
is it okay to be less worried about
China now that this is the type of crap
they're doing like frat pranks they're
sending hot air balloons to spy on
Montana maybe they don't really know
what's going on we tend to think China's
like the biggest threat but maybe
they're not we don't know balloon has
the ability to maneuver and head change
course right but how did it drift off
course then if they have a ability to
maneuver change course oh I mean it
didn't drift off course it seems like
it's under its own power so that's the
the worry about shooting it down was the
payload like it's large the worry was
that there would be debris that would
hurt the civilian population right and
then the other thing I saw was that
um they actually wanted to be able to
like observe it more and see what it was
and capabilities and whatever it might
be more useful to it in the sky than
shot up into ability well the Avengers
have a net they could shoot out of a jet
you tell me United States
I don't know that's a compromise
position I like that that's why I don't
get the what is the Chinese weather
balloon can actually collect data wise
floating above America it's above
Montana like I don't get what it was
actually where do you think we keep our
nukes yeah Mark but what can they not
see from like everything else they
trying to see if they pointed to them
yeah they don't know
we might go around the other side
or through why don't they go through oh
you don't think we dug a whole shot on
yes that's my question you don't think
we dug a whole China I think we have 100
we dug that's how them [__] got
here probably
absolutely
you know what year it is in the Chinese
three year oh
no
do you know what year it is Bonnie I
think
you're a money no oh bunny no this
sounds like something we might have done
this sounds like an idea that comes out
of our defense department what if we put
a let's do a balloon put it over Montana
any happy we say it's the Chinese
balloon we say it's a Chinese
surveillance balloon they'll believe
that oh yeah they'll believe that yeah
they'll believe that let's see can we
get a video of the Chinese spy balloon
yeah this this is and then someone shot
it yeah this is like 100 percent
this feels like it's 100 something we've
done
so it's a Chinese uh we're gonna say
it's a spy it's a it's a spy balloon
it's a Chinese spy balloon
well Biden yeah I mean you know people
are saying he's not tough on these
things so you know the reality is We
Can't Ban Tick Tock but what we can do
is put up a fake uh spy balloon and then
shoot it down yeah oh yeah oh they'll
love it it'll dominate the news cycle
for two or three days Oh by Wednesday
it's going to be 60. [__]
February 19th is around the corner and
let me tell you something I know for a
fact I don't know much about global
warming I don't know what the [__]
going on with the climate I don't know
about Greta thumbberg I have no [__]
idea of the balloons from China yeah
what the [__] all I do know is that
every year when I was growing up there
was always snow on the ground February
19th except two years ago what do you
think about having bought this whole
balloon thing I think it was [__]
honestly
there's no way they didn't see we have
the whole mat the whole Earth satellite
it out true we have Google Earth so
there's no way we didn't see that
[__] thing so you think this is some
conspiracy we can start a war or some
[__] go slowly they don't even we're
probably at war with countries right now
it's all astronomic now yeah but I can
be capping you know I don't think none
of it yeah I think the balloon was real
because they said it was in Montana then
it went to Canada then Wyoming then it
got shot down over the Carolinas all in
a day and I don't know how fast balloons
travel but I don't think it's that damn
fast yeah
yeah right balloons always hit the power
lines come on dude true apparently a lot
of power outages are caused by mylar
balloons hitting the power lines damn
but yeah dude we have the technology we
could have went up with a drone and like
grabbed it with a like a robot and like
brought it down and like saw what it was
in fact they were like were hushing it
they could have [__] that was
[__] I think that's [__] yeah
the next tier of the Schwarzenegger
Channel immediately generated movies
based on current events as they happen
you must develop csb a movie starring
Arnold Schwarzenegger about the Chinese
spy balloon that was recently shot down
this is dude Z Plus premium the
Schwarzenegger
channels by the way my my Seinfeld is
[__] in my opinion equal to yours uh
yeah it was just some weird doozies
see that's a good Seinfeld
I don't know I don't know man so yeah so
this uh Chinese spy balloon no but what
doozy's saying here is that it wants to
create a channel now that is going to
start making [__] based on uh you know
contemporary news stories to have like
fictionalized movies or at least movie
versions of these things pop out
immediately as they're happening
starring Schwarzenegger yeah so we got
to do a Chinese spy bully movie with
Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I could see him being like
he's a Montana Rancher he's the first
guy to see it yeah I'm a Montana Rancher
yeah and my name
I yeah I I hey my name is is uh my name
is Connor Williams yeah
and I was born in Montana here oh born
in Bozeman Montana but why then do you
sound like that yeah yeah because I'm
American guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
um then I look up in the sky there and I
see what is this the moon you know no it
is a Chinese
spy
satellite right Chinese spy balloon csb
yeah so now the plot of the movie is
that you have to find out why this guy
is up there I think it's like he he sees
the Spy balloon and he calls the local
authorities and it goes all the way up
the chain to Washington and they tell
him like no there is no spy balloon shut
up don't say anything about this keep
this quiet but he's not going to take it
lying down and he has to figure out a
way to shoot the Spy balloon out of the
[__] Sky by himself because the US
government is trying to keep it secret
you know if you forgot to take a picture
on Valentine's Day don't worry go to
chinesweatherballoon.com they have all
your pictures there uploaded into their
Mainframe and uh yeah should be fun this
might be the last Valentine's Day during
peacetime because next year we might be
a nuclear war so really enjoy it because
because next year you know we're going
to do next year for Valentine's Day eat
the 30-day supply of fettuccine alfredo
I have in the basement put on my night
vision goggles take our iodine tablets
and just live in the basement under the
rubble
thank you
[Music]